bon michael payet directeur commercial
de la société oyster océan indien côté
technologique études et réalisations on
a plusieurs produits vidéosurveillance
alarme intrusion nous étions présents au
salon de la maison afin de présenter un
produit innovant selek'ha dna l'adn
synthétique qui a été vu à la télé pour
le marquage des objets usuels et de
fortes valeurs nous vous présentons
aujourd'hui la mac briques comme à
l'intérieur des de la vidéosurveillance
avec la toute nouvelle
génération la 360 panomorphe le
visionnage et complet sur 360 degrés
nous sommes une entreprise réunionnaise
tout nouvellement créée il ya trois mois
et nous recherchons aujourd'hui de
développer dans la sécurité électronique
caméras de vidéosurveillance et
alarme intrusion sur toute l'île de la
réunion
aujourd'hui je recherche de commerciaux
est basée dans l'est et un dans l'ouest
qui nous permettront de diffuser
l'ensemble de nos produits sur toute
l'île de la réunion est de permettre
aussi de faire connaître aux hipsters
nous mettons en place une formation en
interne qui viendra compléter la
formation de commercial que vous avez
les débutants sont bienvenus nous
assurons une formation complète sur nos
produits nous recherchons donc des
commerciaux indépendants véhiculer et
autonomes dans leurs démarches si vous
souhaitez intégrer une équipe jeune et
dynamique
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter
bonjour je m'appelle thierry parliez
j'ai 37 ans j'habite à saint trond terry
j'ai une voiture j'ai le permis donc je
vais me déplace dans la région est aux
normes donc de saint denis jusqu'à
sainte rose ya pas de souci je recherche
un poste de développeur en informatique
orientée web en contrat pro finalisation
adultes j'ai un bac pro commerce
j'ai également un bac sti à un niveau 3
en maintenant sa cheville elle est
également un titre de niveau 3 en tant
que développeur en informatique j'ai
travaillé dans le commerce en tant que
vendeur caissier principalement j'ai
fait aussi du porte à porte pour
diverses sociétés
j'ai été commercial pour une agence de
télécommunications j'ai également fait
un stage en tant que développeur
informatique pour la société
réunionnaise dans lequel je devais
développer une application interne avec
langage php et j'ai participé à des
projets aussi informatique pour des
scripts tels que carrefour ifri globe je
fais de l'athlétisme de sur mon temps
libre mais principalement celle du
développement puisque bon j'aime
travailler intellectuellement ici je le
fais pas c'est un manque donc ma plus
grande passion ses yeux le développement
je suis disponible tous les jours 24
heures sur 24
si vous vous êtes même le soir j'ai su
preneur je veux bosser je vais dans le
domaine je veux progresser et faire
progresser l'entreprise dans laquelle ne
jugera
bon jour sur bruno posée j'ai 48 ans et
j'ai deux enfants et six véhicules et je
possède depuis mille ans je suis
actuellement à la recherche d'un emploi
comme mécanicien dans un garage tout
simplement j'habite de la cinquantaine
je souhaiterais travailler plus d'eau
dans les journaux dans mon dernier
emploi j'ai suivi plusieurs formations
véhicules hybrides véhicules diesel et
du possède un agrément climatisation
j'ai travaillé 32 ans de mécanique dont
plusieurs garages macao leur âge espace
auto et speedy sa cuti
façonniers tout révéler d'ici un ancien
formateur de voitures de rallye
j'ai suivi jean cot salle et renée
claude sincère williams modération si
vous êtes intéressé par mon profil
contactez moi
bonjour je m'appelle fayette valérie
j'ai 21 ans j'habite à saint benoît j'ai
le permis je suis véhicules et je
recherche une entreprise dans le secteur
est pour effectuer un contrat de
professionnalisation de niveau 3 afin de
préparer un titre professionnel manager
ibm en chant d'une durée de 15 mois j'ai
fait une année de bts assistant manager
je suis diplômé d'un bac pro commerce et
d'un bep monde absolument chambre j'ai
plusieurs expériences professionnelles
durant mes études dans le commerce et
dans l'administratif pour le commerce et
dans le prêt-à-porter des commerces de
détail et grande distribution aux postes
d'employés de rayon vendeuse conseillé à
mantes et pour l'administratif si mon
post était agent administratif et
d'accueil je suis une personne
responsable motivée et ambitieuse si mon
profil vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
m'appeler
contactez nous sur notre page facebook
www.facebook.com slash 9 7 4 tv ou par
téléphone 02 100 62 92 37 60
de 7 4 cv autre émission au service de
l'emploi à la réunion